[Music]
a couple of years ago i did a movie
called ghost team it was a low-budget
comedy we talk about him a lot very good
friend of ours paul downes that's where
i met paul paul was in the cast and
uh john heater who played napoleon
dynamite and john was so gracious about
telling napoleon dynamite stories and
paul was usually around for it and i
noticed at a certain point paul
would get a little quiet when john
started talking about napoleon dynamite
and then a couple weeks into shooting
paul pulled me aside and he said like he
had some big secret to tell me something
was very like his whole energy was very
like heavy and he goes um
i've never seen napoleon dynamite
whole time so then for the rest of the
shoot i always played it up whenever
paul was around and i i'd asked john
about you know do the line from you know
tina you and john was he would apply
she'd be like no it was tina you big fat
lord or whatever uh he'd do the lines
and and i'd be like oh paul wasn't that
your favorite scene and he's probably
probably like yeah i know i like the
stuff he was so it was so funny to me
john heater would be a good guess we
sure would
we'd be lucky
to have him
here's the show
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long get it life could
be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me is always my brother
please my bad whatever kept that up the
entire time
for the rest of the show for the rest of
the run of life is short you just did a
john heater voice at one po how do you
think wondering would broach at what
point do you think they'd be like hey um
i think quickly yeah
yeah as long as they're listening to the
shows that's true but that'll be a good
test yeah
shows are going great like four weeks
into me talking like that
that's funny that paul hadn't seen that
movie though i know how do you miss that
movie everyone saw that when it came out
well yeah but there are those we've
talked about those movies that like you
missed those really popular dirty
dancing that's true
well
christian and i were doing uh you know
for me it's like braveheart i never saw
when it came out oh i've since seen it
but it took me years and years
braveheart's incredible i know but uh
that's why it's weird oh uh independence
day my friends still give me [ __ ] for
not having seen you still haven't seen
it no oh you should it's really good
there are certain movies uh pretty woman
i haven't seen some movies people get
either you know both of them have seen a
classically pretty woman so i guess i
shouldn't judge him for not having seen
napoleon but i'm surprised that he
hasn't it seems like a movie he yeah
and he's such a you know he paul is one
of the funniest people i know we know
and he's such a fan of comedy you would
think wait what were you saying about oh
how people get interrupted how people
get really incredulous about certain
movies that i don't think deserve it
like you haven't seen blah blah blah i'm
trying to think of one of those movies
where i'm like
it's not that big of a deal that
you know like somebody shamed me for not
watching meatballs a couple years ago
and then i
i saw it and it was like pretty
underwhelming it was but you said we did
a thing oh yeah well that you reminded
me because we were talking about dirty
dancing we did a thing oh we heard that
fox show it was just people watching i
don't know if anyone said watch party
celebrity watch party and uh so then
chris and i yesterday shot our second
we're doing two episodes um well the
first episode one of the clips we saw
was from dirty dancing was like the
climax of the movie yeah and they just
show you pieces of it um and it was kind
of a bummer because i i really want to
see that movie and it wet my appetite
even more now but i saw the i saw the
like
iconic scene you know
so the entire time we were watching
dirty dancing justin and i were talking
about how beautiful and spectacular
patrick swayze was
like it's hard to it's hard to deny we
were gushing about him and after we shot
it we were like uh is this gonna be
embarrassing if this is on national tv
where we're just gushing about how
gorgeous patrick swayze was and luckily
they didn't use
any of it yeah yeah it would it wouldn't
have been though i i don't care i mean i
guess there was a time in my life where
you know that when we were young get
like gay shame there was a real
shame about being gay gay shaming gay
shame you mean gaming oh is that what
you call it yeah did you just come yeah
um yeah gaming was a big thing uh
so paul downs so paul um
why paul why are we talking well he got
his big break because of the show broad
city along with alana glazer and guest
today
abby jacob said
jacobson but the yeah of course it was
abby and alana i mean those they were
the stars and they they created it and
it's a really cool story how that came
to be i love stories like that it
started as this
makeshift homemade fun thing we talk
about that uh so i won't bore you how
did you meet her out of curiosity paul
and alana did a movie called time
traveling bong that is right i was there
yeah and so we went to that it was like
a premiere or something it's a funny
movie it really is really funny it's on
every 4 20 they play at comedy central
it's really good yeah so we met uh abby
and alana at that premiere they were so
cool just like them both so much right
away and it felt like i i knew them a
little bit having seen broad city and
they're very similar to those characters
and
in the best way that's how we met and um
i always really liked her and so
let's uh
you can hear me liking her
coming up right now i can't wait okay
my interview with uh the very likable
and very talented abby jacobson
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
wait where are you are you in
i'm in connecticut you know i got rid of
the place in austin that's right because
yeah i want to talk about that you we
have mutual friends in austin i always
think you're like in awesome likewise
yeah i know well i i think maybe because
when i we i follow you on instagram and
i always
really notice when you post about austin
friends we have mutual friends you too
i'm always like oh yeah yeah where do
you stay when you're there
i just stay at either in a hotel or like
liz has a guest house the best liz
lambert um but i but we also were in
marfa together yes that's why i like
associate you with them and you have
like some crazy story with them that
like
was revealed like when we i saw you were
like i don't know i don't even i was so
i was like pretty drunk but you were
like yeah like i don't know
uh i have a couple of crazy marvel
stories i the first time i stayed in
martha i was i was going on like a
soul-searching cross-country and i know
you've been on those uh i did that exact
thing yeah in pass through my video yeah
uh so for anyone who is interested there
um there's a place called el cosmico and
it's just really like a collection of
airstream trailers there's some tents
there's some teepees which are really
beautiful um
and just the most expansive incredible
skies and i just love it there so much
feels like a good place to be like right
now yes yes yes
would you think about doing that i mean
you're in la right would you think about
it i'm in l.a no
i feel like i'm like staying put i don't
know how you feel but
it would be if i it would be a great
place to be stuck i know because it is
the the
pace is so much slower anyway yeah which
i think we're all kind of like
it's now adjusting to i don't think
there would be if i were there if i was
stuck there i don't think there'd be any
different i don't think i would notice
any different i as it is i'm in the
suburbs of canada i don't notice much of
a difference and is that where you're
from i'm yes i'm so i live about five
minutes from where i grew up uh my
parents are still there and um
i want to talk about parents i know
you're my
i could tell that story in the beginning
but um
your mom and i i love this so much you
are like you are one of my mom's closest
friends that's sue
classic suit um
yeah we just bumped into each other so
funny it's it really cracks me up but
every time she's like he is such a good
boy
he texts me he's so nice well she's very
sweet oh how did i'm trying to i'm
wondering what you i know how cause she
she i mean well i remember how but i'd
love to hear your perspective like so
she was like abby i was wearing the
broad city backpacks so like we got the
rap gift for like season three i think
i'm actually like
i think it was season three
season three
rap gift was like a
backpack that said broad city on the
back in like a little patch and she goes
to key west
like
with her husband and she was like i was
wearing my brad city backpack and
this guy was like hey i know because you
had just worked with paul yeah so paul
downs that's who i mentioned i think on
every episode uh i love by the way
there's paul sent me some stuff to ask
you about
that i'm not excited
okay paul is one of those it's all
questions about paul yeah
basically
how do you think paul became so talented
what was your favorite scene with paul
yes there are some of those uh paul's
one of the paul and his wife lucia or
almost what yeah
i know their
wedding was put on hold uh they were
gonna get married soon but um yeah
they've been together forever and they
are uh they created the show with you
guys right how did that happen they
i mean we
um the two of them are like two of my
oldest improv
community friends
and
from ucb yeah i
i had a class with
i think i had a client yeah i had a
class with paul and then and then met
lucia i mean this is like 2006.
um and alana and i had made the web
series
um in like 2009 and they were the first
two people that wrote us emails and they
were like we put out an episode and they
were like keep doing this
wow they were like whatever just keep
doing this and they were just like
really good friends of ours when we made
the web series oh so you just did this
show did you do it
i mean what was the impetus for doing
was it just like oh we have a funny we
just was just to put your stuff out
there was just it was as simple as it
was like um i mean i don't know
what i don't know like what exactly what
your background in comedy is either but
um i i moved to new york to like
do dramatic acting and then i stumbled
upon ucb and
it was like such tunnel vision there it
was like get on one of the house teams
for improv or sketch and then all you
would you kind of see those people get
on commercials and then get cast and
stuff and that just seemed like the
trajectory the trajectory to like follow
and
alana and i both like could not do it
like we couldn't get on house teams we
like
any audition we just couldn't get
anything yeah you heard that that's that
really
that's amazing it's crazy to think but
i'm so happy that right i'm like thank
[ __ ] god and then we were just
friends and it was very similar to the
dynamic in the show where
she's just like
unlike anyone i had ever met and our
dynamic was just like very unique and
like what if we just made a web series
it's like that beginning they're like
this is the show what if this yeah this
is a show
it was it was truly that we were like
let's make something it was like what if
it was like truly jerry and george like
this isn't this what is this it's
nothing
[Laughter]
exactly it's like hilarious because like
yeah we had we had both seen all of
science well it was very truthful i mean
that also makes sense yeah the show
felt very personal it wasn't um even
some of the like
bra excuse the pun like the broad
characters are still very grounded you
know you like your room even paul on the
show is like
he's doing some extreme things
but everyone's playing it in a very
grounded way
yeah like it bordered
sketchiness but then we always tried to
kind of make the characters very real
right yeah so we so i think if you
balance that you can go
sketchier and then like come back yeah
um but yeah and then when we sold it um
lucia directed the pilot
um
and then lucia was like involved first
so she had directed the pilot paul was
in it
and then when we got picked up they
wrote uh
they wrote for us yeah so you and
produced so you had met paul at he said
you met auditioning together which
yeah i'm like but i think we met in a
class and hit it off and then we were
like we should audition together well he
said
i mean lucia [ __ ] hates we talk about
this all the time auditioning for harald
tv that's exactly what he said so uh
that's so funny here's the text just to
give you put this from paul
paul downs just to give you context we
audition together and always talk about
it and alana and lucia hate it because
we just get nostalgic and they're like
ew
yeah i mean so like the main writers
room of broad city there were other
people like jen statsky was another main
person gabe levin like other people came
in
but it was primarily the four of us wow
wow uh and
the two of them
hate
when paul and i get in because it's
always like yeah remember we went and
got a drink first and like it was like
crooked
and then we like decided to step off the
wall together they [ __ ] hate it they
hate it well because it becomes very um
polarized it like not like insular
it's also ridiculous that we're still
talking about like harold auditions
which were like 10 years it's just
um yeah but it's crazy to me that i i
broad city feels like it's been around
for
you're talking about 2009 2010
i guess that's 10 years ago it it it
doesn't feel like it's been feels like
it's been around for so long but that's
relatively
recent i think i mean
well i mean we did so we did the web
series in 2009 did that for two years
but this show aired in
2014. oh my god that's wild so so at the
website so it's just a matter the web
series started getting a following and
and was it
obviously i mean following would be a
kind okay some people followed it
but there's like a couple thousand yeah
okay all right that's a following that's
more than jesus had
yeah okay sorry i'll attribute that
quote to you
[Laughter]
just the nuts and bolts of it how did
you
were they expensive to do how did you
get the money to do
each of those web series and like the
crew and stuff were people doing it yeah
so it was like it was so
cheap so for the first season we had our
friend rob michael hugo who was a comedy
dude i like found his post on like a
resource center website that he was
looking for like directing and editing
stuff and so he came on and partnered
with us for like the first
10 episodes in the first season like we
separated them into seasons it was like
crazy and then we would pay like the
pizza shop 50 bucks to shoot after hours
and we would anyone that shot we would
like get pizza and like uh our friends
would be extras and it was like just
this community of actors that just like
wanted to be and stuff and um it was all
we would we shot in our apartments and
and most of it was just on the street i
mean it's it's pretty
it's pretty similar to i mean it's not
the same as the show but like it's a
very like the the show ended up being
like a way more expensive version of our
web series it's like very much on
location very like scrappy feeling yeah
it feels that way which is part of its
charm and you always think of like
i think maybe people who aspire to do
what you do and are listening
may think of not having a lot of money
or next to no money as as a limitation
but
i think in your case it really lent
itself to the aesthetic like a really
like accessible it it also lends itself
to like a more grounded acting approach
because
um you can't do a lot of coverage and
you can't do a lot of sound effects and
you sort of have to just trust the
material and you guys had such great
material and i think that's what and and
then it also amplifies like
how simple comedy can be how like bare
bones it can when it's good it's just
like you don't need much i think yeah i
think that we
and i mean now i realize it even more
like how lucky we were to have
that dynamic i mean i think like the
hardest part i think is finding
the dynamics between character and like
fleshing out character and if you if you
find characters that
and develop characters that you can put
in any situation
that's it totally yeah and so like once
we like
i mean in their versions of us so it was
like kind of a trial and error of like
how much we amplified ourselves
because it's like
a lot of stuff we like hate him can't
stand about ourselves and like all our
insecurities are like right on the
surface so it's just sort of like how
much
we were comfortable with doing it but
then once you establish it then it's
like well we could put them anywhere
yeah abby that's interesting did you did
it make you like self-conscious about
certain traits that you had that you
were realizing during the writing or the
you know the process of it
yeah um
and also amplifying like the differences
between the characters too uh
i think
yeah like
it really and i can lean on the fact
that they are i'm amplifying those
aspects of myself but yeah it's like
just showing the insecurity and like the
blabbering like
like but then again those are the most
fun things to play and i see
taking a [ __ ] fake phone call is my
favorite
i will put that into yes i mean i just
did a show that was in like 1943 and i
like i was like i can't do my thing like
i don't want to like
but i'm like i love that that oh yeah
like
that kind of have you seen kate burleigh
cape verlande has a great bit with a
banana yeah with the best oh with her oh
my god yeah with john earlier i mean
where she takes a fake phone call but
she but a really serious she plays it so
serious but with a banana or with
something i [ __ ] i could watch it
every day i realize like a lot of that
stuff the stuff i like the most is the
stuff that you can do
on kids you can like show to kids and
they'll it'll make them laugh yeah
yes like where it's like physical but
yeah that's my favorite
how did you meet alana then did you meet
her at ucb as well we met um
so not actually not like at ucb but when
when i went at least um you would take
classes and then you kind of formed
these practice groups yeah on the side
like at night you would like have a
group and a team and you'd hire a coach
like bobby moynihan was our coach oh
and like they would come and coach us
and
um
this guy tim martin who
we had on brad city he's like a real
he plays this guy dale who's like a
redhead alana's like creepy roommate
that like has her remote yeah he
he was dating alana at the time and i
was on this practice team with him and
he was like hey can can i invite alana
and her brother elliot
and then they came and joined the team
and i truly thought um like the first
practice i was like oh
[ __ ] like my like
maybe from arrested development is on my
team
[Applause]
like now they don't it's also the hair
yes they do have similar
features yes and so we
i was like wow she's this is crazy the
show's over of course she would be doing
improv and then we went to a bar we went
to mcmanus
yeah yeah
we went to mcmanus and i was like
talking to her
and we were just hitting it off and i
was saying about how she's from long
island and i was like oh i have these
two two of my best friends from college
are from long island
and i was like they're from smithtown
and she's like i'm from smithtown and it
turns out ellie and her brother knew
both of my friends
and i was like this is not this is not
the girl from arrested development
this is just some other person also um
yeah yeah so you were like i loved you
on arrested development and
yeah i i i played it cool yeah no it was
not her and then we were just on that
improv team for two years
we we joined that team in like 2007
and we were on that team for two years
and then we we started the web series in
2009. so you so she was just somebody
that you by the way have you ever told
jacques alia so ally shaw cat's the one
you thought she was have you ever told
allie of that story so she know so i
don't know what season it was we did an
episode
that like so much of like my life i got
to like just put right as an episode so
we did an episode where
like we really styled her to really look
to match the hair too where alana is
like abby
i met someone
and i'm dating her it's incredible and
then she brings her to meet
me and i'm like dude she looks exactly
like that's really funny
that's so funny because we i on this on
this show we were just talking about um
we were talking about the phenomenon of
gay couples who look very much alike
and and i didn't know there was somebody
wrote in
and said there was a term for it have
you ever heard of this it's called
you know this
i don't know the term but i've i i've
talked i've like noticed i've like had
this conversation with people what's the
term it's called boyfriend twin
boyfriend yeah it's a i guess it's a
fairly common and it's not really that
like
i thought the term was going to be more
exciting it's like
part of it you're like you're like it's
called no wait wait like it's called gay
boyfriend twin stop the most literal
it's pretty self-explanatory
no you know what partner don't find it
part of that was because i i didn't mean
to i was just like do you know that and
then i paused
i i guess that was more of a rhetorical
question but then so much time went by
that it felt like there was a build up
to something like you ready for this i'm
glad you're sitting down
boyfriend yeah oh you're gonna love this
uh but it is um
it yeah like i guess there are there are
a lot of people
i i live in chelsea in new york and i
you know i i see it all the time there
uh there's some straight couples though
that that kind of got it going on too
yes where i'm like are you guys siblings
yes my friend uh i don't know i don't
think you'd mind me saying this mike
herzlinger uh my friend michael i hope
he's listening um
mike and his wife
uh and they laugh about it well you'll
know after this yeah i will that's true
he'll come out
out of hiding but mike and his wife
they look so much like siblings and i
think i don't think it's insulting to
either of them because obviously they're
like attracted to the other one
you know no i think it must be like some
sort of like comfort
like attraction i don't know what it is
but that's funny and alana's case with
shock at it's um
there's there's also so the funny part
to me is like there's some there's a
level of narcissism
oh yeah oh we've we like really played
with it like i want to see yeah
episode yeah it's i think it's in season
two
or three and it's like i'm gonna spoil
it it's not just not as well but we did
a scene where like
she's going down on alana and we made it
like a lana it would like pause back to
him and oh and she was like i can't
[ __ ] do i can't do this anymore
she's like i see i see i see it even
that part of her looks like me that's
weird
yeah yeah
that's funny uh so it was just you guys
had
just a natural i mean is it as simple as
yeah we just hit it off we just clicked
like you would with a friend
it yeah we were just i was we were also
the only two women on the team uh-huh um
i don't know yeah we just like really
hit it off
and we're just
very good friends and we perform and do
you miss and then i think we both got to
a point where we were not getting on
anything
and decided oh like we gotta let's like
try and do something else like like and
also
i'd been doing improv and sketch for a
while and i
uh you know had a day a lot of different
day jobs and i think my parents
maybe behind my back whatever we're just
like what is she doing like it's not and
so it's time to pack it up
yeah we could send them a link
when you do the web series it was like
this is i made this thing right because
when they would come up to new york and
watch an improv show at like under saint
mark's theater for like nine people
where we were like giving out like jello
shots it was like what are you doing
even more it's like this is what you're
doing this is like a college thing this
is like
an extracurricular
yeah that must be for parents i'm not
saying that's what it is because i love
that kind of theater like i love going
to smaller though i missed that ucb uh
126th street but um
i could i would imagine for parents they
want to you know
they want some deliverables i think like
i mean once it got going like
they would come to those premiere
parties and be like wow yeah this is
like so fun and it felt so grassroots
and diy yeah i mean the
the
it wasn't like right it wasn't like um
it it clearly was not like a immediate
success even though people maybe
think that it was from watching this
show well it's also only was like
critically
successful it took a while
it was never like a huge viewership um
but
but the fact that you went you took it
from this such uh homemade kind of thing
to just the fact that it was on tv your
parents must have been so excited they
were and like every step along the way
was like hold on amy's involved like
what are you talking about like
it was was that the moment so what were
was that yes that was the moment when
amy got on board um did you guys just
pitch it to her
yeah so we were doing the web series and
we had we were like we're gonna this was
2012 i like no dates we were gonna come
to la and pitch it um in september of
2012 and we were gonna end the web
series in may and
we wanted to do a bigger finale of the
web series and we're like what if we
asked amy poehler to be in it that'd be
that'd be incredible i saw this thing
online that she was in town
she did a speech at something and it was
like do you want to do this thing next
week and
we put more money into it and it was
more like a short film
it's pretty intense it's actually
it's actually we own this is so
like maybe narcissistic and douchey but
for like real old school like broad city
web web series fans we homaged our
finale
in the tv finale
so like the cold open of the finale is
very much it's like running through the
city which is sort of like how we always
felt like these girls are always [ __ ]
like disheveled and sweaty and
everything is like a hustle it was real
amy
oh cool and then afterward we were like
we're going to pitch this
do you would you ever want to be an
executive producer and she was like yeah
so she so abby but like she wouldn't
have agreed to do that had she not seen
real potential in it like somebody like
amy poehler is not going to just put
herself in a
diy type you know because there's tons
of those things a web series
yeah it was i mean when she was when we
shot the web episode with her that was
like
that was the ultimate
it was it was that like i think that was
the biggest
validation oh yeah because we wouldn't
we couldn't get on a herald team and now
like amy is the founder of ucb and now
she's going to be in our web series it's
like what it was like better than like
any other thing oh my god and we made
her say stuff to us in the
dialogue is like
you guys got that it was so it's so
absurd the web episode to say like she
was saying like um
kind of motivational stuff like uh well
we're running through this city and you
don't know what we're running for and
we're just running to get a chocolate
chip cookie
before they like run out and she
we just made a beat where like we pass
all this stuff along the way and one of
the beats is like we're running and then
all of a sudden amy's running with us
and we're like hey man she's like hey
guys and she's like and then this thing
happens and she falls and she's like go
on without me it's like so dumb um
but it's
and then um
yeah she
just from a practical point of view abby
how do you do that like i've shot in new
york i've shot low budget things in new
york and it's always so frustrating
because people don't want to
you know new yorkers are
going about their business and they
don't want to be
interrupted i mean now it's like
which is why what's going on now is
whatever presenting
massive problems but like just just on a
much
less important scale like shooting
something how do you shoot a low budget
thing where you don't
have pas like keeping people back how do
you do that just practically
well i mean one like one we were not
like known to anyone yeah but still you
guys so and there's like no cast really
there's like a little scene happening
here
uh like we would have like one or two
people okay so it's not like people
wouldn't walk through the shot or were
they um they would they would and if
they did
um they're in it because also we didn't
make any money off of it oh
okay so like
no we didn't we used any music we want
and then actually we had to end up
taking a lot of the web series down
because comedy central bought it
and so
yeah or like they had to buy the
ownership or whatever yeah but um
yeah it was really
i mean the finale it was insane i i'm
from philly i took like a bolt bus
to philly
like two days before we shot this finale
the web series and borrowed my stepdads
like rav4
and like a big scene is like with all
these oranges i had to buy like all
these oranges drive up to new york
alana's dad
drove the rav4 and we put the camera in
the back of the rav4 with the top back
and that's how we shot me alana and amy
running like oh my god that's very by
the way like yeah you could never get
away with that uh no it was in the
middle of the west village like you did
it on like commerce and barrow oh my god
oh my god it's like
nuts
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wandery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
do you miss that like now you're doing
bigger things you're doing things with
bigger budgets and and with bigger casts
and
do you
miss that kind of like uh homemade
aspect
i do um
i mean i think i missed that like
like the
i don't know at that point we were i was
just like making so much more too
because it was like
we were precious about it but also not
because we were like what if we did this
and then it was like yeah let's do that
versus now
i just did this pilot and it was like
you know just everything takes so long
yeah and like to figure out every minute
detail and
i think maybe also because it's
it's about it's this is more like
dramatic like dark
like dramatic comedy balancing act
whereas brad cd was way more like this
gut
like we just trusted our gut yeah like
what is funny what we think is funny and
then we're like let's just make it like
and then that that kind of stayed into
the show the tv version
so i definitely missed that yeah what
was that i'm a little it's a little
harder to like trust my instincts when
stuff is like
you know you take a month to decide like
the scene and
you know and when you overthink comedy i
mean you have to overthink it obviously
like in editing which is something i'm
going through now with my brother but
improv is just so immediate that's why i
always feel like my first take my second
take maybe whenever i say the same line
again it always loses something yeah
you're like i'm not even it doesn't make
sense anymore yeah i don't forget what
it's about now i don't know but i see
that need your and your mom seems like a
creative person i i see i s she does i
see but i see that in she really is yeah
yes in your
you have that
impulse to create and and you're doing
it you've been drawing you're doing it
with your drawings now and and um
i mean i'm not now um i feel like i only
draw
when i'm
like like i really haven't been creative
throughout this
time
well at all like i've been editing and
it's like it's i've been doing stuff
that's like on zooms and like there's
already deadlines in place yeah i
haven't made anything new for it seemed
like you had up until the because you
had done a really cool thing you posted
about um where you were drawing people
you were drawing people to their like in
front of them i did it right before that
yeah i looked
it was a little bit like whoa wait yes
it was like the weekend before
quarantine but that was truly like
it happened so fast like i didn't even
think about it but i'm gonna okay so i'm
happy you brought that up because
yeah i did a thing where i did like um
it was a hundred bucks
and there was it was a hundred bucks for
a portrait and i did these like really
quick portraits portraits in person with
people and and it went directly to the
this organization cielo which is in la
and they help uh people without homes
sorry abby
s e l a h
s e l a h l okay cool i thought for a
second i thought c-lo it was all going
to
yeah very different oh yeah okay very
different yeah that's a really good
thing
yeah
uh or you can send the money there
yeah but um it was like i had been
feeling which is hilarious now i had
been feeling really disconnected
and yeah
it's so funny
um
and so it was like this wonderful day of
like i had a timer and it was like you
know it was like these weird mini
therapy sessions where i would like talk
to you about how they're doing while i
do them
and it raised all this money and it was
just like this incredible day and
i've been thinking and i actually tried
to do it but the organization like
we couldn't figure it out i'm trying to
do a virtual one that's i was just
saying that that's per it would lend
itself to that i would imagine
yeah where it would be zooms yeah um
it's just about figuring out
logistically like how people can sign up
and i can schedule it
but yeah i also i always feel weird like
trying to raise money
yeah i know well right yeah
i know i know what you mean like because
they're they are mediocre drawing
like they're not you know like i'm not
art's not like my first thing so i know
but i but i like it so much because
they're they're they come from you and
and there's they're definitely good
enough to it's not like they're
you know they don't they're not like
scribbled you can tell what it is what
you're drawing yeah but it's more about
the experience exactly the experience
and it's like a hundred bucks which
isn't like yeah i mean it's a lot of
money for i mean it's a chunk of money
but it's also not like crazy
and it's going right to the organization
exactly it's all these things are good i
don't think there's any downside to it
and presumably there are people who are
fans of yours and it's like rather than
getting like a selfie or even an
autographer it's like oh that's
somebody's signature it's like a cool
like piece of your art it's like from
you a very personal i think it's awesome
i all right i'm gonna do it i've been
trying to do it i was thinking of doing
it for world central kitchen yeah yeah
because i wanted to do um like a new
york uh organization this time yeah but
world central kitchen feels like it's
like everywhere it's wherever there
needs to be help
i think that's a great idea there's i
just so um meals on wheels just reached
out i've done stuff for them and i i
hadn't thought how important how much
more vital they're gonna be now um just
getting
meals to people uh yeah i think that's
great abby and because we're lucky and
we have
if you're able to if you're able to
raise that kind of money with a drawing
uh i know i'm i'm i feel that way too
i'm like i'm not doing i know i don't
know if you feel this way i mean
i think that this is affecting everyone
this is like difficult in any way
and it's obviously
like i feel very lucky like my family
and and friends are healthy
and i'm like in this house you know i'm
very
fortunate and i'm
i'm now and the whole time i've been
like i'm not [ __ ] doing anything i
can give money
yeah which is like what i've been trying
to do but like hands-on like time
how can i
i don't know absolutely and and just the
fact that you are it's something that's
interesting to see so it's a visual
medium so you can put it on social media
and i found that that has been such a
great social media always used to scare
me so much but it's
to use it uh in a positive way has been
really um i found it really like in
enriching and i don't know i think
that'd be i'm excited for you to do that
uh and and so and it would encourage you
just selfishly to be
creative and you sounded a little down
when you were like i haven't really been
doing stuff
the day that i did that it was like it
was so invigorating
yeah totally
i like what you said about it you felt
more connected to people
yeah look i bought i got all these i got
stuff to do i have all these pads of
paper over here to do it you're all
ready there's no excuse i'm really all
ready i'm really happy we're talking
about it because it's holding me
accountable i would say we could start
right now you could draw me but i'm
really worried how you would it's like
that it's like gargoylish um
are you how is that uh just with people
now knowing your face how has that
changed your life what are some of the
or or has it really
um yeah i mean i think for me it's like
it depends on like where i am
i mean i would i'm very curious to ask
to know your
your
insight into that too
i don't know i feel like um
i feel like i'm pretty sure
yeah yeah
that's a good
part of it not a good part of it that's
a that's maybe the most all right not
like bonus no no i think maybe like for
dudes it might be
better uh
i think that's a misconception well yeah
it depends we're like maybe more dudes i
that i know use it right i don't ever
use it like it only makes me more
insecure like
people know me but i don't know them or
see i think that's a misconception
that's probably a misconception i would
have had whenever i'd if i ever like
had that fantasy of like you know like
everyone oh if i was a famous actor one
day i i
i don't quite remember how that felt too
and i don't think it's something i ever
i certainly didn't do it because of that
but i'm sure it was a component of you
know wanting to
it's the reason i started doing plays
was to meet girls um in high school but
um i think that is a misconception
people have that it's it's better for
that kind of stuff i agree with you i
think it's um
if anything it really
narrows things and and it makes me
question
people's intentions and yes yeah where
i'm always like
like on a first date or something i'm
like
i'm asking a lot of questions
like that's what i feel like i'm always
like asking a lot of questions and no
one like a lot of first dates like i'm
not dating anyone right now and a lot of
first
yeah it's very hard why not right now
yes
i might not date anyone ever again
um but why have you been so anti-social
yeah well i said a lot of things but um
no i feel like i get really in my head
when i'm when i notice like oh they're
not asking me anything
and then i'm like well either that's a
thing that's like a maybe that's just
how they are but i'm also like or do
they know
or do they know about me here's my here
would be this would be my concern maybe
paranoia is that they do know and they
are withholding they don't want to
reveal that
they know by asking
the normal questions that you would ask
a person that that was a relative
stranger you know
yeah i mean it it it sucks because it
makes me
oh this is shitty shitty to say but it's
also like where i meet people more like
it's been a little easier to date people
in the industry because of that uh
you're preaching to the choir because
i'm like they're always skipped over
that whole step and i just there's like
a
totally and comfort already of course
and it's such a bond yeah and it's such
a unique thing to do not that it's so
difficult certainly not difficult or
anything but
it's such a small group of people who
have that experience and it's a very
uh important experience i think for
people to share um
and there's also and it's also the
scheduling and like right
the work mode of
sometimes i feel like i'm
i don't i want to find a new word for a
workaholic but like i find that
i i have a hard time like work-life
balance yeah or i often work more
and
i don't know i found like people in the
industry have a similar they're like
doing similarly wired yeah yeah how you
had i i know you tend to get i you
strike me as something i'm this may be
way off base but
you struck me as someone who gets very
productive creatively after
uh i know you did after you went through
a breakup you i think you didn't go
cross-country and you just started
creating yeah get really productive
after after that like i'm like man
channel it
yeah that's great yeah
i mean i think i i had always wanted to
do that i'd never driven across the
country i'm kind of like itching to do
that again i know me too when that would
be but
um would you guys yeah and i
where would you go
well i went south i think i would i
would go
north or maybe right through the middle
i don't know i want to do that yeah i'd
love to go through like montana and i've
never been to montana or the dakota
exactly
yeah
it's there's so much of this country
that's like [ __ ] gorgeous
and yeah i haven't experienced most of
it how did you meet uh we were
mentioning our friends liz lambert and
aaron smith and our austin ladies the
austin crew how did you get to do you
met them through just going to marfa
um
i met them through a friend oh okay okay
okay
okay
uh abby has turned she's wearing a pink
shirt she's now the color of okay um i
see yeah well uh i really like their
friends so
that's i'm sure it was a it was a lot of
mutual friends yeah i find most people
know them yeah i you know i would love
to talk to liz on the show because liz
good
fascinating and a good friend and she
for those of you who don't know liz owns
the or did the san jose hotel saints
still saint saint cecilia hotel and
interesting time to talk to her right
now i know i know um
she is has a company called bunk house
and
they refurbish a lot of
dilapidated and
properties she's just a really creative
person and
such a great story but she's sort of
responsible for taking that i lived
right off of south congress for a while
i lived in
on the street called pecan grove and and
that
that part of this austin has just
changed so drastically even from the
time i lived there which wasn't that
long it was like
10 the last 10 years has just changed
everything and i mean i've only been
going there
for like four years yeah and i feel like
every time i go i'm like
oh there's a made well here
i'm like
just like i i mean and i didn't even
know it i i guess i i had been there
maybe
in like 20 yeah like
2013
and did walk that strip but it was like
very different so different so imagine
that then
even from 2004 and anyone who
knows austin also knows that there are
very few remaining like true austinites
like liz who um
who remember at times there's a great
documentary she did uh called i think
it's uh i'm sorry i'm forgetting the
name but something about san jose early
days last days last year
wait justin she's like read they're
recutting it i've been telling her to do
that so good oh uh good
good i've been yeah like she's doing it
because i told her david david garza
yeah
like i think that she's yeah she did say
that she said justin
said it and then says i just want credit
yeah
i told her i did tell her yep that's why
she's doing it um no i'm so glad because
uh it needs obviously it needs to be
updated it's like this
it's all about the when the san jose
hotel was this um
really like dilapidated old uh motel
that was frequented by mostly
pro like by the night yeah yeah yeah
there's a great play called by lanford
wilson called the hotel baltimore it's
missing the e and and i always think
about that so funny the hot album yeah
it's a great play um
uh anyway uh love liz and so much more
to talk about i'm sorry because i know
we're short on time now i want to get to
the
speed round
um
there there was something else though i
was gonna say to you while you're in
quarantine oh the thing that you're
editing what is that
oh can you not talk about it no i i can
um it's just a pilot right now um
we're waiting to see if it gets picked
up but it's a team something you wrote
i did i co-wrote it with um will graham
um
it is a tv version of a league of their
own oh oh of course of course i yeah i
knew that i thought that was
oh of course yeah i thought you should
oh i didn't know if it was uh i remember
you talking i wouldn't oh maybe i did
tell you i was like i don't know if it
would yeah if you would know yeah it's
um
i it's with it's with amazon
you know how it it's like who knows now
it's with them like we we basically are
just finishing up like the sound
right now
and then um but
it's i really like it yeah i mean you
know maybe abby i heard you talking
about it on andy
um oh yes yeah maybe or andy rifter andy
richards yes sorry uh um but it's very
yeah it's um
is it i love the movie i love the movies
like it really holds up in certain ways
but there was like a lot more going on
obviously at the time so that was kind
of darker for
for a movie with tom hanks
like yeah yeah it's yeah i mean we don't
even touch on the coach uh
yet because it's just that's too
like iconic of like a character yeah and
no no characters are from the film it's
all different okay so it's not like
there's no sobbing in baseball no okay i
don't know if we just change one word
but none of the characters are the same
like i know it's people's favorite movie
there's a lot of pressure the movie
still is right here okay and ours is
right here um but
like uh the film
doesn't really address any race issues
or sexuality
or
um like there's a lot more happening in
the league
yeah i'm trying to i'm blanking on the
character's name but they they
allude to one character's homosexuality
she's kind of like the very tough
rosie rosie is it is that what it is
i mean they don't even allude really i
don't think like she says something like
yeah they always he always thought i was
like weird oh like there's all these
like
and there's a foul ball um foul balls
into like
the fowl area yeah
and in the film um a black woman
you've learned a lot about me yeah
really learned a lot
a black woman picks it up and chucks it
back
and uh to gina davis and she's like ow
oh yeah just to show that it was like a
hard throw and then that's it but in
reality black women weren't allowed to
try out wow
wow yeah so this version is very
different and
um it's it follows the league and also
um
like women that weren't allowed to even
try out in the league so wow that's cool
but it's all so funny yeah okay
it sounds funny
um hi there's a lot there's a lot who
else is in it abby okay so
this cast is
nuts okay so speaking of caper lamp oh
she's in it yeah she's in it she's the
oh god she's good darcy cardin oh she's
great too from the good place yep uh
shantae adams
she was in roxanne roxanne she's like a
legit movie star oh cool
um
uh benizola aikumello who is like huge
in in london
um roberta kalindras
great names wow really good names yeah
um
molly ephram
um
um
i'm gonna maybe no no that's
that's exciting so so what's the problem
is it because i know with networks
there's a very specific schedule and
this might be boring for some people we
can cut it out but like what what is the
amazon is there a deadline that they
have to tell you about are there
like contractually they probably have a
deadline to like
tell us
or like we can take it somewhere else
but um
i think they are going to do internal
testing on it okay
and then we'll see what the masses think
about it did they still test it that way
didn't they used to test it like on
their platform
yeah i'm happy or i don't know if it
would be better that way i don't know
how they
exactly who they're sending it to okay
because i think they would be doing it
like in person so i don't know how it's
happening right now but they used to do
it yeah where you could like watch
pilots uh-huh yeah i thought it was like
such a good idea it's like yeah why not
this is like a built-in um
uh okay that was going down but it's i
mean i'm really proud of it i think it's
really good jamie babbitt directed it oh
wow he's great she oh she oh sorry sorry
did she do the muppet movie am i
thinking of somebody else he did like um
oh i love him love him
british
um but i'm a cheerleader oh i'm sorry
i'm thinking of um
jamie bobin or uh
bobbin bobbitt jimmy bobbitt sorry
uh but i'm a cheerleader it's great i
know that one too uh oh [ __ ] okay but
i'm a cheerleader yes she did and like
she's done like every tv show just a lot
of silicon valley um
i mean i'm excited yeah silicon valley
that movie is fantastic
uh
oh my god yeah jamie bobbitt life could
be a dream
oh also i was told by paul to ask you
to ask you about uh fish you're a big
fish head
is he making that up
no i mean i feel bad saying this that
i'm like not any more like oh it will
always have like a special
place and i always have a place in my
heart for them yeah yeah
and they're like i got to meet them
oh no and they're lovely yeah but you
don't go to shows anymore i went to a
show
um
like two years ago
a lot of my high school friends i mean
that is like high school yeah totally
yeah my high school friends too yeah
everyone was like we went to all
we went to like all the jam ben shows
every reincarnation of the dead like
i would see like phil and friends and
rat dog like all this stuff and then it
i it was more about the experience too
that's not my kind of music that i kind
of go to right now
but i took a bunch of my high school
friends to see them and we got to meet
them it was pretty rad uh that is cool
i'm sure uh i'm sure it'll be one of
those things and i have those where you
revisit it you get stoned a couple years
later it's like i forgot how much i love
these oh when i whenever i hear it i'm
like here we go yeah like i know every
word like i could go i could tap back in
like i have love for them but it's just
not my
jam right now yeah i think it's more
like the scene the scene of it is like
yeah that's a big part of it i think is
having to be part of it yeah and and not
in a bad way in like a really cool it's
the environment of going to those shows
oh the fish parking lot is such a cool i
don't i don't know it was always a fish
pond
yeah
yeah uh
what is uh what is your most commonly
used emoji would you say oh i'm not a
big emoji oh okay i would say um you use
them sparingly maybe like the woman in
the gown oh like the flamenco dancer
like that oh okay weird yeah
or just like a smiley face or a heart
i'm pretty i'm pretty tech no
yeah me too i i yeah i've been doing you
know what i've been doing the one a lot
is the um
this is not a visual medium so i'm going
to try to describe this but i'll just
show it to you like that smiley face but
like um kind of looking down a little
bit like
a little like
like respectful yeah yeah like
smiling but slightly looking down in in
what context uh like um use it in a
sentence
like like i want you to know that the
thing i said was not was meant
not meant to elicit anything other than
like oh here's some information for you
and is that in a kind of nice way
okay yeah
i guess i'm really benign i guess yeah
yeah subtle i guess i'm saying a lot of
benign things to people um that's not
something to brag about uh if you could
be a professional athlete what sport
would you play
soccer oh easy you grew up playing
soccer yeah well you grew up in
philadelphia hilarious i say soccer as
i'm doing league of their own um oh no
no i i did i played travel soccer oh wow
so i was like 15 16. oh wow oh so you
were yeah i loved soccer
that was my sport i have memories of
being in the
playing goalie and like praying to god
that the ball didn't get kicked to me
like literally dearly i can't imagine
goalie i would i never played goalie
that's insane like it's scary
because when you're a kid the kids who
aren't good at kicking and stuff like i
wasn't good at or running they put you
in the go they just put you in goal
which doesn't make sense because the
like goal is really important yeah yes
yes i know
uh were you religious growing up evan
did you were you raised with
i was not religious um
i'm fully jewish we were really really
reformed so like i went to synagogue
um on all the
the holidays and then i did i did get
about mitzvah so i went you know sunday
school hebrew school on wednesdays
but it was so um
it was like on the big day it was so
like half-assed because i learned to
read hebrew but not what i was saying oh
weird it's so it's really upsetting
because i'm like what did i do all that
for i can't even
weird i don't even know what i'm reading
oh my god that's crazy it's like a way
to it's like performative it's like a
way to teach the kids to perform at the
show of their bar mitzvah yeah and we're
going through this motion and then it's
like
great
bizarre i wonder what i said
no idea what weird wow yeah it is
but a lot of that is i mean i had um and
my parents won't like me saying this but
even you know i had confirmation and
first communion as a catholic and
similarly it's it's um it's a
performance it's a
and now i can only imagine how it's like
you taking the pictures and yeah it's a
rite of passage it's like
this is a thing like where you're
growing up and everyone comes and
watches the thing and do you have no one
knows
what you're saying yeah i get i guess
passover was in quarantine did you do
anything with your parents for that i
didn't um a zoom seder
you know i didn't
i
usually when i'm in new york like this
is the first year i've been in la more
than new york i do go back and forth but
i when i'm in new york i always go
because i'm from philly so it's like
very easy i just do all the holidays um
in philly but
no i didn't do anything
i mean
my jewish holidays here everything is
just big on locks
that is me being jewish it's very cliche
you're a cliche jew yeah
um
do you go to ever go to your into key
west with your speaking of uh being
jewish do you ever go to key west with
your parents
i
um i went with my mom when i was in
college uh-huh
yeah we never even finished that story
no that's i know it's just a bookend
that's how we bonded
i guess i i'm so you said hey to my mom
i'm playing yeah like she was leaving
right like
we were on a plane from miami i think or
somewhere in southern florida to key
west like one of those little puddle
jumper like smaller planes and um which
always make me so nervous and
i it's a combination of like being
nervous but also on the way to key west
because i love the keys so much i get so
excited you know so i'm i'm i i get kind
of chatty and i like meeting people and
i and so any like slight connection to
somebody and so i saw and as we
mentioned paul is such a good friend and
i think i just like we hung out i think
we met at like there
at time traveling bong yeah um and i had
just started watching broad city and i
was like it's like to meet you guys and
um
i don't know so i saw the backpack your
mom was wearing that like
and i was like yeah we were walking i
was walking behind her and i was like
i'm sorry
why well i noticed you were wearing the
backpack like you have some connections
and she's like as a matter of fact i
just she loves it yeah anytime someone
is like i love that show
well
my daughter oh my mom to every i mean
that's you know yeah but this was years
ago and you guys have kept in touch
yes
well because you were
your grandmother lives down there and
yeah you were in touch about like
maybe selling her house or something
right yes i was in touch about well i
was actually looking for property in the
keys like i was down there looking at
some places and i ended up not getting a
place there but my grandmother's in
she's near
west palm beach like worth area so i've
been coming from visiting her we talked
about that um but and we also
your mom was like yeah well i think we
just kept in touch because i wanted some
advice on and she was thinking about
maybe
getting a place there i think i don't
know you just kind of because they go on
they go at least once a year yes yeah oh
i know
uh
yeah i love it i i i miss key west so
much but she's always like she's like oh
i i talked to justin recently he doesn't
need to text me back but he did and it's
so nice
like she says she texts you if she like
sees you in a move like yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's very sweet it's something my
mom would do
with a friend of mine that she doesn't
really know well but isn't she sees in
movies and stuff so i i like it um
and if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life what would it be
oh man
probably like kettle potato chips
oh yeah that's good right oh god it's a
classic classic uh
what's your favorite movie have you are
you cooking a lot in quarantine i am
cooking a lot that's cool that's good um
i mean
not nothing fancy i'm not even following
really
uh recipes i just feel like i'm getting
these csa boxes out here oh yeah great i
gotta start doing that yeah it's i mean
i feel like you might be a little bit
more limited where you are yeah
california there's like [ __ ] producers i
know i've been seeing my friends are you
a vegetarian i'm a pescetarian oh okay
okay so how do you feel like roasting
lots of veggies and doing different
things like that like nothing fancy
are you what are some of your go-to
restaurants in la that
if you were to order i
i love all time i didn't know that
on the east side okay um i love this
place jewel that's actually vegan
actually was great yeah are you no no no
but i've been wanting to eat more been
trying to eat less meat and eventually i
would i aspire to one day be i don't
think i could ever be a full-on vegan
but pescetarian i think i could maybe
manage you know it's interesting i think
maybe lucia might have gone back on it
but
she was too like we all had been for
like years once and my dad
um you met my stepdad but my dad and his
wife
started like a year ago too and they're
pescatarian and once you like do it it's
like this is you don't even think about
it anymore and actually jewel i never
ate beef but um
jewel in a lot of places make stuff that
like you wouldn't even know uh-huh
they do have options i don't know i just
yeah
there was a place in silver like i
really missed this indian place called
um samosa house i think oh i've never
been i'm on the east side
i wonder if they closed down oh you're
near like faux cafe and like oh i really
miss that area but they they good area
that's great but they made a dish with
jackfruit that i got really into yeah
where you're like this is just as good
why is it not yeah yeah yeah
okay i know you have to go i'm so sorry
um uh really quick and and i always have
to ask this what's your favorite movie
of all time or do you have one
if not you know what it's a movie that
i've been thinking about
because i love it so much and i you i
can't find it anywhere
the name is so perfect for me right now
but it's called an uh it's called an
unmarried woman oh yeah and it's coming
to the criterion channel in june but
it's like
i can't find it anywhere
and um
it's just like
it's by paul rajersky
like oh i love her
who did i think that's how you pronounce
uh
yeah and it's like new york
uh jill claiborne oh i love joe clayburg
you would okay you would okay so i think
this is the only way you can watch it in
june on the criterion channel but it's a
gritty new york in the 70s the
soundtrack is so good there's like and
it's about like
like it's about like heartache which i
[ __ ] love clearly
um art there's an artist like it's just
so it's just all the things oh wow i
love clayberg for those of you who yeah
jill claberg i think the last thing she
did was uh bridesmaids she she played
kristen wiig's yeah she's what a
wonderful [ __ ] great actress and
there's like a group of women in it um i
gotta see that all right it's really
wonderful what's your favorite movie uh
i
love back to the future i love old woody
allen i you know uh yeah
no yeah sorry i know annie hall i still
love it um yeah but i i would say back
to the future i think it's a perfect
movie um
during this
yeah i've been doing that a lot
revisiting all tootsies tootsie might
be up there i definitely up there if not
my favorite so i yeah it's been fun i
find that comforting you know oh yeah
going back and
hanging out with the old favorites um
i love frank oz i love all his movies um
if you uh
if you had to live somewhere else you i
know wait how are you doing on time you
got three minutes i just need five
minutes yeah before one so i'm okay i
just need to let my dog out oh i love
that your dog too i've been enjoying
have living vicariously on instagram
photos of your dog okay really quick uh
your dog is like this [ __ ] podcast
um
if you could live somewhere else where
would it be
um
i feel like somewhere like wyoming or
utah or montana like
jackson hole or something mountains and
like more nature if you could have
dinner with three people dead or alive
whom you've never met
it's not a very good lightning round
question
i mean i gotta say like i bet everyone
says oprah
oh i think he's doing obama a lot of
people say obama hey you know what
surprisingly
i don't i'm sure one person has but no i
don't hear it no i mean i love oprah
yeah i guess it would be oprah
um dead or alive
yeah just someone you've never met
you've never gotten to meet never okay
all right oprah gilda radner oh yeah oh
yeah definitely big for me yeah and um i
love that documentary about her i'm
pretty sorry i know i read her book
when i was in high
school yeah
um
i think it's called
oh i can't i can't it's a great book and
it was like about her being sick it was
just really lovely
um
i was a very big snl fan oh i bet i was
yeah i bet during the so that'd be like
the welfare just before will ferrell
like that or those days too early in
high school i mean yeah i was like a
cheerleader i mean i was mary katherine
gallagher for halloween i was a
cheerleader for halloween i did coffee
talk
like for my
class like peers i was that was my
[ __ ] thing um
okay
i gotta pick another person right
maybe uh
yeah now i'm thinking yeah gildarander
is great yeah but you can think about it
we could come back to you think about it
okay um who's your favorite muppet
no not a okay uh if you could have one
superpower what would it be
i mean i think it'd be pretty rad to fly
yeah yeah yeah it's so funny like yeah
it's such a people always couch that and
like i hate to sound basic but
but it's like that would be pretty rad
yeah yeah um if you could be uh if you
could be reincarnated as a non-human
animal if that if that
is what happens to us what would you
want
to be
well i mean first
thing first thought is a dolphin
oh yeah
i don't know i haven't
a donkey it's no a dog it's fun just
because i'm i'm just like think i'm
guilt-ridden about your dog's full
bladder oh no it's okay maybe that's
just on my mind no i guess that first
thought would be like that like a
dolphin in the sea like you're so happy
oh my god but then yeah
yeah um it's funny whenever people
answer this it just happened to me with
you i i picture
your face on like a dolphin it's a
really funny visual i get visuals very
easily um would you rather be called
unattractive or unfunny
would i rather be called unattractive or
unfunny
i guess unattractive
yeah
yeah i guess i always think it depends
by whom you know like
if it was somebody well because i'm like
i'm sure people
think both
not not not i'm hoping that like most
people but yeah no but like i'm sure
people think both and
i don't know i think like one would buy
i think an unattractive thing like i
think physical stuff
i i could have more of a self um
assessment yeah
not that i'm like you're wrong but i'm
like okay like i know like whatever but
i'm more confident yeah like i'm not
like
okay
it depends on what day you saw me but
like the unfunny thing i'm like um
yeah that would bother me more that
would get to me more yeah me too um uh
which golden girl do you most identify
with dorothy blanche rose or sophia
dorothy
that's funny yeah that's easy yeah okay
it's funny how you answered that you
answered that like dorothy would um
dorothy dorothy yeah uh
uh dogs or cats do you prefer
dogs
okay uh dogs with empty bladders uh
beetles or the rolling stones
um
i should probably have said like fish or
widespread panic we'll definitely fish
but yeah um you know what i actually
it's so weird
answer but i i think i
i like the rolling stones better but i'm
way more familiar
with like the full
yeah the catalog of the beatles yeah i i
don't know why how that is never seen
them in concert
no uh abby thank you
you're someone i've always really uh
liked every time i see you i i just
i know we gotta actually hang out in
real life i know i know one day one one
day post quarantine hey you me my mom oh
yeah
i mean i'm sure you'll see my mom more
before you see me
probably i'll definitely hear from her
um yeah
uh which
paul what else did he say oh you know
what's funny just a uh
just a and the paul thing he said the
last thing he texted was
you could ask her her favorite qualities
in paul w downs
i know that i knew that that was coming
yeah yeah i would say his charm
his muscles
is paul's deceptively uh
fit like cut
oh he's really good at getting cut yes
yes yes
yeah
i mean there's nothing not to love i
know i know um well if you're listening
paul we love you and uh and and if
you're listening sue
uh we love you too we do love you we do
love you
and i apologize to your dog it's okay i
have enough time okay all right thank
you abby thank you so much what a
pleasure really yeah thanks for having
me
[Music]
that just happened
is it well that just happened oh my god
you know that just happened or so that
happened that's crazy i don't know now
you know i'm more way more confused than
i've ever been i think well that just
happened because i think we've done it
different ways i think i think it's well
that just happened would that be a
catchphrase
no it's already a catchphrase is it is
it arrogant to say you have your own
catchphrase yeah but no but i think
anyone even with a small audience even
with like
among family members can have a
catchphrase do you remember steve
urkel's catchphrase sure uh and can you
do the voice
did i do that
yeah i wish you could have seen what
your face looked like when you did that
voice oh carol you look like gollums
oh my god we've been talking a lot about
steve urkel and
that show the plot of that show which
lasted like we look we went down a deep
deep pearl hole the other night and
stefan arkell when he started playing
the cool
character um
that's i gotta say the fact that jaleel
white was able to pull off those two
characters at that young of an age
is pretty remarkable oh yeah it's really
impressive the range he had remember
when we hung out with him that night
comedic actor yeah i do yeah and he was
much more stefan or kell he was exactly
like
he was he really charmed both of us oh
yeah he's great in fact he'd be a great
guest him he would he'd be a good you
know yes we keep meaning to lamorn
morris is friends with julio so maybe
first we have lamorne and then we
hit him up for jaleel's info good idea
speaking of stephon or kell yes abby
jacobson yeah how cool she's cool huh
she's cool she's more stefan than steven
she's very um
she's she seems like a fun easy hang on
she is yeah the few times i've i've been
around her she and that's why i think
she attracts i feel that way about our
mutual friends
so um
yeah i look forward to
hanging out with her outside of this
quarantine yeah there's there's
something about her kind of easy energy
that that
makes you realize how
uh like one of the reasons i think broad
city became such a phenomenon is because
those two women were just so easy and
fun to watch yeah and so much of that
show is just like hanging out with them
hanging out with them totally and i i
after hearing that conversation it it
helped
me understand why exactly that show was
the hit it was yeah
there's something really uh
listenable about her you know
and i don't think they like but another
thing on that show is they don't put on
heirs they're it's very it reminded me
of starting out in new york and that
feeling of being
young and and kind of feeling when
you're young in new york feeling when
you're ambitious and young and living in
a small apartment in new york
yeah but that show broad city is like i
i've only seen a few episodes of it i
think and i i've always liked it but i
have friends who like revere it yeah you
know it's it's very very very popular i
think it's it's
specifically it's very very popular in
the gay community
oh well you know gay guys love that show
yes that's where um and i have a few gay
friends who like oh really
like did you hear that was that your
stomach yeah it was well it's i don't
know if it's technically my stomach i
think it's
gas that i was kind enough to not
release thank you for uh sharing the
information and not sharing the fart oh
you're welcome
uh yeah
and that's where the term speaking of
that community yas queen oh yeah you're
right
i can't believe you didn't talk about
that with her i know
ah what's the opposite of yes queen no
king
i know [ __ ] because no peasant
stupid
nah it would it wouldn't be no it'd be
like
yeah [ __ ] we talk about that all the
time i mean we use that all the time
that's kind of slipped into now i'm so
curious if it were vernacular
now i'm so curious if it was a
particular manslaughter if it was abby
or uh alana who
came up with it or paul or paul
[ __ ] that would have been a good why
didn't i
i'm like anchorman if it's not on the
thing i don't i don't ask her about it
and [ __ ] you and [ __ ] yourself san diego
what do you say
uh i don't know yeah go [ __ ] yourself
san diego such a good but that show
broad city is like
ah it's like the creative version of the
american dream that's their their
success story yeah those two with that
show you know
like
two girls who couldn't get on one of
those improv teams yeah kind of rejected
every step of the way it's such and then
and then inspiring and then
taking it upon themselves to start this
web series pulling together resources to
shoot this thing on a very low budget
and then it becoming
this like massive
uh phenomenon it was now it's become
like this iconic thing but i think the
key to it and is what she touched on is
that they didn't do it for the purposes
of then becoming successful they did it
they were just [ __ ] around they were
having fun
right i think yeah you know but maybe
it's also they wanted they wanted to
show yeah either way it's really cool
well it's also and i've noticed this
theme
with a lot of like throughout all these
interviews really most of them anyway
is the desire to please your parents and
and everyone and we've talked about this
before but that desire never really
fully goes away with people you know our
we've talked about our our parents
mothers are both still alive they're
both 103 years old and there's still
an element where they're trying to
please their parents yeah look what i
did it never goes away so in this case
she mentioned that she said
you know my my parents kept asking me
like what are you doing you're just kind
of floundering uh
doing you know doing these improv things
right
they were so
she seemed so desperate to
show them something
to impress them that's true so i think
that was part of the impetus too to be
able to send them a link to an actual
thing that they made right that's very
related jason biggs talked about that
too you know wanting to please his
parents you're right it's a real common
it's a common thing and i'm sure
something that a lot of uh if not all of
the listeners can relate to well that's
why you're doing this podcast too to
please your parents yes please and
they're not listening um no they are i
think they are they are i'm just kidding
just kidding uh you guys talked about
uh boyfriend twins the concept of
boyfriend yeah and it was funny how much
you built it up and you were like okay
have you heard that there's this term
for when a couple looks like she's like
yeah what is it and she was all excited
and you're like it's boyfriend twin
she's like oh that's
it's not that exciting
i know i know but but she's right but
you said that your friend mike from high
school his wife they resemble each other
and you're right and you said
you said something's effective i don't
understand why a couple would be
offended
by the that comment like oh you guys
yeah yeah seem to resemble each other
i know a couple who very much resembles
each other they look like siblings a man
and a woman
but i would never say that to them
because it's offensive and you know why
it's offensive uh
yeah because then you're saying one
looks like um the man looks like a woman
and the woman looks like a man no that
too that too but no no
not that because because a brother and
sister when you say oh you guys look
alike you're not saying that oh you're
the sister looks like a boy that looks
like a brother true that's true or and
vice versa it's not that it's that it
implies incest oh
if you say oh you guys are like siblings
but you're really having sex with each
other oh you're right and that's why
it's offensive now would you find a
like if if a man looked like your ex one
of your exes that you at one point
presumably found attractive
are you thinking of somebody
um
would you find them more attracted than
you know it's really hard to picture
because
uh
all my exes have been women and
it's it's
when you just know what someone looks
like it's hard to picture them as a man
because they have a like a woman face so
but i'm trying to i'm trying to so maybe
abby wouldn't find him i'm trying to
picture an ex with like stubble and a
backwards baseball hat on if i dated
both men and women let's say to add to
the hypothetical
and i pictured a male version of a woman
i've dated i would guess it stands to
reason that i'd also be attracted to
them in male form you would
i think you'd have a hard time don't
don't be offended i hope you're not
offended by this but i think you would
have a hard time getting the type of ma
mail that you would be really attracted
to
a patrick swayze or a tom brady
i don't know how i couldn't be offended
by that
i mean think about your taste in
male beauty
that's that's different though that's
like admiring a uh who would be
michelangelo's david or something yeah
so i like the men that i consider like
super super attractive
are not men i want to touch they're just
men i who's whose
beauty i can
recognize for celebrity watch party as
being beautiful you know yeah yeah so i
but you're right like if i were to like
who would be if i were to date a man
of course i know i would never be able
to achieve
something like that who would be your
boyfriend twin mine yeah
who's a good example of that who's
someone who just looks like me yeah
like if you saw like a famous person
yeah somebody that people know like if
somebody saw you two together they'd be
like oh boyfriend twitter well i guess
you so wow except for me
i walked right into that one um who else
uh people have said i look a little bit
like
who have they said a little bit like sam
i guess um yeah you do like a little not
right now maybe but
who else what else david i get david
david schwimmer yeah
you get i don't look like jimmy fallon i
look a little like david schwimmer uh
the flattering one the most flattering
is a jimmy's flat
counter yeah that's a flattering one
uh you know would be a funny name for me
for like a poor man's keanu reeves keon
no
porn man's porn man's kiana piano yeah
no reeves
um
anywho any who
have i done my uh gps impression my old
school this one would be very better i
would be able
i won't be able to do this any longer
because i don't think gps is sound like
this anymore but it's this take a left
on martin luther king boulevard
go thr go straight on main street
well you have to flick your tongue when
you do it yeah
take a look take a ride down mainstream
and
i didn't know that they were remaking a
league of their own that's cool yeah i i
haven't i haven't seen that movie in a
long time i'd like yeah that'd be a fun
quarantine watch it would and that's a
movie that i can understand if people
got incredulous about if not having seen
that's a classic yeah yeah but how are
they going to rema that's the thing it
must be very daunting she talked about
this the um
how much pressure there must be to
remake something like that it's like
remaking jaws or something you think you
think it's on that level
yeah i think it's just as it's a class
it's one of the certainly one of the but
top that's true but she made it sound
like it was very very different in tone
like there's the coach character for
instance yeah arguably the most popular
famous character in the the movie
version played by tom hanks is not even
in the show and it's isn't that
interesting that a movie at that time
shows you how much has changed
culturally
for good is that at the time that was
considered such a progressive i remember
like oh they're
showing the
moment in history right and they didn't
even address the
racial racial or
homosexual uh
um that was 93 i think it was a much
different time yeah
uh i didn't know you had a secret
friendship with your mom you didn't no
you never told me that
yeah i didn't no i mean it's not like
how come you didn't talk about that well
because it's like very benign i mean no
offense to susan it's like not a deep
friendship so it's not yet it's not like
scandalous
no okay no it's no way scandalous yet
uh no in fact she texted me the other
day she she's really yeah she's so sweet
we text every once in a while i guess
you must have a lot of texting
relationships with people that you don't
share with me no so i shouldn't be
offended no i don't really that's that's
kind of it
um do you want to read a letter yeah i
really like her susan i hope she's
listening here we go okay
here we go hear that bird chirping yeah
isn't that nice yeah
i thought it was we have a bird clock
that makes a different bird chirping
sound i thought it was broken on every
hour yeah it's stuck on the hour yeah i
thought it was going on too long yeah
you know because you know it is the hour
oh yeah so i thought it was the bird
clock
it just occurred to me that the sound of
birds chirping um
can be either really annoying or really
beautiful and relaxing depending on your
own mental state and depending on the
bird
yeah yeah some birds are like ah
you know what birds are annoying species
that was a good bird yeah that was good
what do you think that was a raven
they have they have
yeah
i think that yeah it sounds like uh
it sounds like an angry person screaming
yeah what would be the human equivalent
of that crow
hey you're going there what are you
doing
that's good yeah yeah
you know what birds uh also have a
pretty annoying sound it's one of the
few
annoying parts of austin is uh the
grackle
how does that sound it's like
ah that's similar that's that's uh raven
raven vibes yeah it's in the ring what i
like chickadees how's it sounds like
they're saying
oh it's like the frog there's a frog in
puerto rico
that
goes cookie remember we went to puerto
rico yeah what are they called cookie
fries cookie frogs yeah kooky let's read
a letter okay but anyway that yeah those
birds
can be really those birds those birds
though
you don't hear that a lot anymore those
but is that i think some of that uh
social media vernacular just like comes
in a secular
vehicular sweetheart okay
uh okay this is from dominic
s
hands down the pants on the legs
okay and yeah you're he's showing me
that they're on his thighs but barely
no fully they're just okay
subject thank you life is short bros
hi justin and christian congratulations
on one year of life is short i've been a
big fan since day one thanks dominic
that's very cool a whole year that
dominic spent with us
i am writing and i'm writing in to say a
big thank you for the show well big
thank you back i was given some chef
knives a few days ago as a present to
cheer me up during this lockdown as i'm
a keen cook i was from england
unfortunately these knives are crazy
sharp i slipped cleaning them and
severed my thumb i was rushed straight
away he didn't say straight away i was
rushed into emergency surgery to
reconnect a tendon i was so frightened
about going to the hospital during this
pandemic and catching corona as well as
the fear of being operated on for the
first time in my life
the nurse
sorry
it seems like uh
it's pretty
weird to hear such a sweet i know
accents okay such a gruesome story it is
isn't it
yeah i should have heard his thumb jesus
i i wasn't even paying attention i was
too caught up on the accent i'm sorry
but yeah now that i think about it the
nurse calmed me down and let me take my
photo my phone the nurse calmed me down
and let me take my phone into surgery to
listen to something as i only had
injections to numb my thumb oh my god
whilst the fantastic nhs doctors in
london worked to save my thumb
i was listening to you dax and christian
to distract me from the bloodbath to my
left oh my god dominic
thank you for being there for me long
time
long fan
thank you for making me laugh for so
many years jesus that's crazy
i love the show and can't get enough the
quarantine check in episodes jerry is
too funny we love him over here jerry i
hope you're listening you hear that i
bet he's listening yeah i bet he is too
i think he's a shorty yeah dude he's a
cause he's a guardian he's a
concentration sending you positive vibes
and well wishes dom from across the pond
oh god british people are great dominic
kind regard kind regards classic yeah
dominic seabrook london england
classy yeah sending you positive vibes
and well wishes dom i like that across
the pond um
thank you so much dom that what uh and
yeah what are you right what a great
harrowing or i know grizzly uh so he
severed it you know someone just sent me
these knives i gotta put them on
instagram because someone they made a
custom knife and now dominic's got me a
little nervous to
uh you just cut your thumb i did
thankfully it didn't require stitches
but it's still pretty gnarly oh wow yeah
i'm looking at it uh i've never had
stitches you ha
i have well yeah
yeah i don't remember it that well
though uh i was so frightened it's god
crazy and sharp yeah i wonder who made
the knife it's a strangely good
advertisement for uh i slipped cleaning
them oh christ
anyway that's so nice uh i mean that's
not that's not nice but the fact that uh
we were there isn't that strange the
idea of
being people hearing us and from all
walks of life and different countries in
the emergency room oh my god it's so
it's hard to wrap your head it is i know
it's pretty surreal so yeah thanks for
um
thanks for that dom it's nice to get the
because because you have to understand
that chris and i are we're in this
little room we're just kind of talking
to each other
so sometimes i forget that
it's amazing yeah better people are
listening yeah also for better for worse
i mean like i think sometimes i forget
that you know i have to be
i have to keep the ball in the air like
i cannot go down like weird tangents
well i'm glad you're okay dom yeah thank
you for listening and writing and if you
guys want to write in our email address
is
life is short at wondery.com
and we love uh dom has been listening to
the quarantine episodes if you have to
you'll know how much we love the would
you rather so any of those are welcome
and also we want to highlight a local
business that you want to highlight so
mention those two and keep the letters
coming we love them and tell us how you
make the most out of your life yes and
thanks to abby the wonderful abby
jacobson god that was fun and uh and her
mom sue and the whole jacobson family
and to alana and lucia and paul and
everyone responsible for that great show
broad city and thanks to dominic for
writing in and uh thanks to jerry and
all the shorties for listening jerry
o'connell listening um
and we'll see you guys in a few days
yeah
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long and it's produced by you christian
long and megan monaco senior producer is
michelle mish
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are martial
[Music]
lopez for wondering
see you soon
[Music]
i mean
it was impressive that that actor could
play both parts i think erko wasn't
urkel intended to just be
if not a reoccurring character like
maybe even just like one episode one or
two episodes
oh really i don't think urkel was a main
character he was you know
i think it was that's that's what's so
crazy about all this these plots uh yeah
they had it all mapped out the season 10
apparently how the show continued into
the final season myrtle oh oh that's
helped stefan piece together his part in
the oracle line
it's truly insane
because i think when we watched that
show in the beginning of
the run i think it was just like a
normal um
it was like full house
yeah she was like cute yes i remember
her of course
yeah she loved she was crazy about urkel
right she was like weirdly
yeah and he was like no thanks mine
right think about it wasn't he like dude
and he always reviewed her it never made
sense
22 episodes it was like total 240
episodes or something on the show 225
episodes how do you keep oh my god you
have to start doing weird [ __ ] like that
i know but to go from
a norm how do you go all the way to that
i mean it's one thing if like okay urkel
has another girlfriend and then like
she has a cousin that he prefers i get
like well because but to make a cloning
machine and [ __ ] like tell you why
because i think they realized very early
on and certainly by season five that he
was the he was by far
the start of the show how do you keep
that character that nerdy who doesn't
live there
not only that how do you keep him not
only does the play not only doesn't live
there but it's like
nut is like
not oh my god
i mean like he's such an extreme
character well that but
but uh but that he was popular because
of that so let's just i know but i'm
saying how do they but how do they
generate plots around him around at a
certain point if he's that's right he
didn't live there he was a neighbor he
was the annoying so how many times can
that main character know but like the
central character in the show
how often can he get rejected by laura
and how many times true can carl be like
get out of here steve like i'm busy
like
after four seasons of that they have to
start like having clone machines
it's true
you